so everything we do as District
Council's is about community day-in
day-out the way that our staff interact
with each other with councillors is
about community it's vital that we have
celebrations such as tonight to
celebrate and reward the communities and
everything that they do absolutely
fantastic to be able to award these
awards tonight to celebrate the good
work that people do throughout our
communities in Mid Suffolk Baber they're
very generous with their time and they
do such a fantastic job it's just a
pleasure to be able to do this tonight
I'm looking forward to seeing the look
on people's faces the expressions when
they receive their award there are some
truly magnificent people in our area we
are very blessed to have them around we
work with our communities we work with
our businesses and our staff day-in
day-out are working hard alongside our
councillors to engage with those
communities and so to actually be out
celebrating with others is fantastic
tonight to be here it's just fantastic
to be able to celebrate with local
people at their success and their
achievements this evening will celebrate
all the hard work that the community
does
I think we should celebrate our
communities because there is so much
work done behind the scenes this
voluntary work we couldn't do it all
ourselves and we need to help the people
to do it they do it willingly it's just
a fantastic event for me I think it is
great to see as leader of Bebo to see
what what's happened through the
district things I see in here a lot as
as leader but not everything and there's
a lot this evening that I've learned and
you things that don't don't cross my
path during that the normal day-to-day
worker has been leading the district and
it's just a lot of inspiring messages
and stories that have come out of this
evening to make the numbers up come away
with two two awards it's amazing and
it's something that I love doing and I
enjoy doing I've got a fantastic team
behind me
it's like coach disability football and
I've been doing it for about 15 years at
cornered dynamos I've had a fantastic
evening and yeah we're really happy I
don't think I could say any winners
today because they are all deserving of
the prize even the ones that we run as
that play they're all winners
you
[Applause]